I Steve junya hard American urban radio
networks congratulations once again I
love the fact that this is the book 12
years a slave is now number three on the
new york times bestsellers list do you
feel that this has been a complete
teaching moment now because of this
movie for the world really well for me
it was always my ambition to get this
book into schools from day one when I
read the book the first time we're
working with people in the UK when
working with people in the US to try and
get this done you know to unearth
someone like Solomon Northup to an earth
the sort of an American hero which was
lost 450 years and you know it gives me
great pride that we know that we've won
we've made this film which I think it's
kind of not bad and that we've resurrect
this novel which I think you know
everyone here will now know his name and
throughout the world which is which is
fantastic battle against me to this film
is too hard to watch I think
particularly here in the United States
do you feel like you're winning that
battle at this oh for sure oh for sure I
mean look at the box office here look at
the box office in in Europe we've passed
100 million dollar mark so you know that
just proves that that is not at all a
question to raise any more I mean it was
at the beginning because you know that's
what the Greeks were possibly predicting
a great movie by difficult what but it
just shows you the audiences are
interested in challenging films audience
are interested in films which sort of
give them a perspective of of the
history and where they are now and
hopefully where they can be in the
future and again in a slavery as a
subject matter I mean slavery was not
was never abolished it was deregulated
there's still 21 million slaves living
today as we speak
Jimmy will you know it's a very serious
film and we're proud of your
accomplishments but this whole circus of
the nomination and Willie win and Billy
Baldwin how are you handling that and
are you having any fun in the middle of
all of this oh yeah like it's like your
birthday every day um no plenty someone
told me very early on Steve this movie I
mean it's something which possibly
beforehand I wouldn't wouldn't have done
I wouldn't have gone round wouldn't have
done this but some said me Steve this
movie is more important than you and I
understood that and I took that with me
and actually you know again it's been
wonderful it's been great meeting you
meaning you in spring because bait
what's happening is a great debate is
occurring through something which was
lost 150 years so every QA I've done
it's been it's been it's been almost
like a town hall meeting passionate
vital present so it's been you know I've
had such a great time but can I have a
couple more questions please i love this
i mean you know oh oh really okay yes
okay hello
well that wasn't Nestle the case it was
we came together as a group of
filmmakers from catering here makeup
lighting sound department camera
Department grips gaffers logicians it
was there was a foundation of of people
a family which came together to make
this film so it was we as a group made
the movie in a way that it wasn't at all
a burden yes they were hard scenes but
you know as a collective we came
together to make this film so it wasn't
at all difficult it was actually an
honor to represent some a north of story
now that's it okay great thank you guys